[Music]
hello everybody this is Garrett Rollem
and I'm very excited to be providing a
2-day train the trainer course at the
2019 our studio conference I'm gonna be
joined by my colleague monnet Chetan
kaya Rundell and between the two of us
we'll be teaching you how to teach are
in workshop settings and then how to
specialize in teaching either the tidy
verse or SHINee
so I spend my time in our studio
teaching people how to use art
specifically the tidy verse in the past
are marked down shiny but rarely do I
get to teach people how to teach and
those are the thoughts that are closest
to my heart it's sort of a naughty
secret in industry that corporate
training especially in a workshop format
is not very successful but there is such
a need for corporations to hire trainers
to come in to teach their employees how
to do data science or how to code with
are there's a huge shortage of our
programmers and data scientists and at
the moment the university system can't
supply the demand so what do we do well
we need to learn how to teach are
effectively in a workshop setting and
luckily here at our studio we have lots
of experience doing that and lots of
opinions on how you could do it well so
in this workshop I'll be teaching you
the things that I've used in my
workshops to win awards to create happy
students and - I hope succeed better
than what's average in the corporate
training world we'll be looking at
things like how to build mental maps for
your students to use how to give them
the sort of details that they will rely
on after the workshop but there's no
hope of them really memorizing in
completion during your one or two day
workshop we'll look at learning theory
we'll look at how to design a course to
keep your students motivated and
interested and how to deliver your
content in a way that the students will
remember in a way that works with how
the human brain is set up and then
finally we'll look at how you could use
some technologies such as our studio
cloud or learner tutorials to actually
increase how much your students would go
remember after the workshop this is
where workshops are working against us
you only have a limited amount of time
with your students but it takes time and
repetition and forgetting and
remembering and coming back to a subject
before student can really master it we
can't deliver that in half a day one day
two days but we can use technology to
follow up with the students and help
them build those neural connections so
go make your material last and persist
in their memory and I want to show you
how to do that so I encourage you to
visit the our studio conference website
and read my workshop description as well
as the descriptions of my colleagues
workshops I look forward to seeing you
at the conference
[Music]